Let me ask you a couple more personal questions,
if you don't mind.
You mentioned
briefly during our,
during our conversation that you know,
you,
you were,
you're from a pretty fundamentalist Christian background and you became a
skeptic and you'd be pursuing that with,
with,
with well adamantly,
let's say for a very long time.
So two questions is
what put you on that path and what do you think your positive function as a
skeptic is?
Yeah,
so first of all,
my family wasn't religious at all.
They weren't antireligious to just wasn't a thing.
I became interested in it and the early seventies when I was in high school,
which was sort of the early development of the Evangelical Movement in the
United States.
So I called born again movement,
and there was no affiliation with any church or particular,
we all recognize that,
you know,
organized religion was probably not all that great.
So just sort of a one on one,
it's just you and Jesus and the Bible,
you and God and so on.
And uh,
that was that whole,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
superstar time and all that.
So,
but I took it very seriously and I went to Pepperdine and I took courses in the
Old Testament and New Testament.
I read everything cs Lewis wrote to the course in the writings of Cs Lewis said
I was into it then.
You know,
at Pepperdine,
you're in the bubble of the Christian worldview.
This totally consistent.
It's internally coherent,
uh,
until you're outside the bubble.
So when I went to a secular university and to study experimental psychology,
um,
not only was that more of a grounding in the scientific method of understanding
reality,
but just for fun.
I took courses in,
first of all,
I took courses in evolutionary theory.
I was kind of a creationist.
I remember sitting there thinking,
Holy Shit,
this stuff is real.
There's an actual site.
But then I took a course in,
um,
and mythology,
anthropology and comparative mythology and that kind of opened up my eyes.
So I sort of went through my Joseph Campbell stage and the myth of the hero,
I read the hero of a thousand faces and all that.
It's like,
okay,
this is,
this is a different way of looking at things than the pure scientific way.
But it's also different from a lot of these religious traditions,
you know,
so that,
that's sort of told me that the particular religion I was in,
it's wrong to ask,
is that,
is it right or wrong?
It's just,
it's a completely different thing.
And,
and it,
it just wasn't working for me anymore.
So,
and I enjoyed the scientific way of thinking about the world and I was
surrounded by people that it's not that they were atheists in graduate school
and after that it's like,
remember this is now the late seventies.
And then when I went to graduate school in the second time for my phd and his of
science and late eighties,
um,
again,
the whole eighth science,
religion,
atheist,
new atheism,
that wasn't a thing.
No one really talked about it.
It wasn't like a big thing.
You have to decide,
are you at the east or an atheist?
No one talked about that.
And so my focus is really on this,
on science and understanding things.
Now the problem with being a sort of an intellectual or historian of science
psychologists like I am,
and you're interested in study beliefs like I do.
Um,
and then also being a public intellectual is the publisher of skeptic magazine.
And I write this column for scientific American every month I got to essentially
debunk something or analyze something is it kind of puts you in the role of
like,
well,
I've got to say if this is right or wrong,
this is true or false or,
or something in between.
So I,
I'm,
I'm us constantly and just kind of razor edge between,
I just am curious observer of people's beliefs.
And then on the other hand,
I have to actually have to kind of pass judgment in writing every month,
well as this one correct or not correct or something in between.
Um,
and,
uh,
so,
again,
it's at that different levels.
You know,
sometimes I'm just talking about people's beliefs.
Other Times I'm at,
I'm actually kind of forced to say,
well,
I think this is probably true.
We're probably not true.
And,
uh,
and I think this is,
you know,
I listened to,
I tried to listen to that first podcast you did with Sam
to get through it again to me,
you know,
two hours you were just talking past each other at different levels of,
Sam's laser focused on,
you know,
people will behave,
they act on certain beliefs and you know,
the obvious one flying planes into buildings is because you have a certain
belief that leads to that.
Yes,
that's true.
And it would be good if people didn't believe these things that lead them to do
those kinds of violent x.
But there's a whole nother level you can talk about beliefs that have nothing to
do with leading to violence or so on.
And to me it just depends on what's your goal when you're talking about this
particular thing right now.
And,
and you know,
so there I was good friends with Stephen Jay Gould and you know,
I was sympathetic to his noma
in the sense that the world's already to tribal and so if we can calm everybody
down,
that's good.
On the other hand,
I do think science and reason can inform and maybe even in some cases to
determine human values and moral decisions right and wrong and so on.
I've written quite a bit about that too.
And so,
but again,
that's sort of a different level of top of what you're talking about and what
the goals are at that particular moment.
Yeah,
well,
I mean this,
the skeptic when,
when,
when I think of a skeptic,
this is a strange leap of course,
but um,
there's a,
there's a scene in revelation where Christ comes back and he comes back with a
sword coming out of his mouth and that's where he divides the damned in the
safe.
And that's,
uh,
that's also an image of the logos,
right?
The word that brings forth order out of chaos because partly what you do as a
skeptic,
it isn't so much that you dam the untrue is that you rescued the true.
And that's really necessary for people because we need to stand on a rock.
And one of the big problems I have with new age movement,
and I've kind of studied this technically looking at the way that creative
people,
because there are creative people who are critically minded and there were
creative people who are not critically minded and non critically minded.
Creativity seems more associated with mental illness and psychopathology.
Or you have to be able to discriminate between what's worth saving and what
isn't,
so to speak.
And that's what a good skeptic does.
Cause the skeptic isn't necessarily someone who says,
oh,
this is all false.
A good skeptic is someone who says,
oh look,
there's a kernel of truth here,
but it's deeply buried under layers and layers of,
of rust and nonsense that needs to be burned away or polished away so that we
can get to what's absolutely essential.